his relationship with the White House
spans two US presidents but India's
Prime Minister Narendra Modi needs more
than just official support he needs the
Indian American community to with his
economy struggling and tensions high
with Pakistan over a dispute in Kashmir
Modi will be in the US state of Texas on
Sunday to rally supporters and one of
the largest and actually most prominent
diasporas is the Indian American
community it is rich it is well-to-do
and it is very plugged in it's one of
the main reasons US President Donald
Trump in an unusual move will join Modi
on stage in Houston a beachy bar Trump
Sarkar in his 2016 presidential campaign
Trump courted their vote and even though
most Indian Americans voted for his
opponent Trump will need all the help he
can get for his re-election bid in 2020
he's also hoping to sign a trade
agreement with Modi to counter the
ongoing tariffs or with China which many
analysts believe is hurting the US
economy so if they can announce a mini
trade deal it would be a triumph of
sorts for both sides and all this comes
before both men are scheduled to meet at
the annual meeting of world leaders in
New York at the United Nations Kimberley
hellcat al Jazeera the White House